her grandkids toys were in the back and
the key I wasn't into out cuz you felt
like a star Bing bus I was like being a
top athlete in Division three so I was
at the show and this old lady came out
to me and she put her hand out and I
shook her hand and she's so wrinkly her
hands are so wrinkly like that right no
oh why do you smile I don't know
but in her hand there was a note so I
grabbed the note and she goes I'm a big
fan I go by and then I read the note
call me if you want a good time as I was
I was like Ross right and then my friend
Kevin I go this oligo she have you ever
had hooked up with an old lady I go no
you should try so I called her next day
and we were at dinner and she goes yeah
by thinking my breasts done and she
pulled her breasts up like that and
shine your titties
I have grandkids oh and then I was like
yeah and she had this like a van with
all these kids toys Roller stroller and
we just went back there and I made out
with her during the day okay during the
day yeah yeah so do you understand what
like the alura's know yeah but I didn't
get hard so you just made out it was
more of a science thing oh so you
weren't turned on it was like no I was
like resupport lips are wrinkly did you
learn did you feel like you were doing
like a charity thing no I just found it
to be yeah I guess there was an arousal
because you know she was like this older
white lady I'm this little music lesion
divorced Swiss recently divorced and so
I'm like you know there is something
about how Stella got her groove back so
what do you know I think what it is it
has definitely has to do with an older
white lady right who dated this he was a
fireman right so he was like a fireman
white burly man white and now she's
making out with a fat dumpling in the
back of the [ __ ]
ban me and she's like six foot and I'm
like a little and she's just grabbing my
fat rolls there's something cool about
that like yeah this is what you get now
yeah I really don't get it birth like I
think I get it even less than that made
no sense whatsoever there's a food truck
coming out called fat dump later check
it out
do have a question or what we got now
okay let's do a question I'm hopeful but
I just say this so I mean
[Music]